the judge has rejected former president
trump's bid to keep the special
committee investigating the assault on
the capitol from seeing his white house
records mr trump immediately appealed
the decision which followed a series of
new subpoenas seeking more information
on the january 6 attack that left five
people dead chris van cleave has more on
last night's ruling
a federal judge in d.c delivered a late
night blow to former president donald
trump denying his effort to assert
executive privilege to prevent the
release of white house documents to the
house committee investigating january 6.
in her sharply worded ruling judge tanya
shutkan wrote presidents are not kings
and plaintiff is not president
addressing executive privilege she found
this is a dispute between a former and
incumbent president and the supreme
court has already made clear the
incumbent's view is accorded greater
weight
as the committee continues to look into
who may have been involved in the
planning of the capital attack
the documents would likely include call
records white house visitor logs as well
as notes and even twitter direct
messages from the former president
committee vice chair wyoming republican
liz chaney at a new hampshire
fundraising event this week and at this
moment
when it matters most
we are also confronting a domestic
threat
that we've never faced before
a former president
who's attempting to unravel the
foundations of our constitutional
republic the select committee issued
subpoenas yesterday to 10 additional
former trump officials among them former
press secretary kelly mcenany who was
with mr trump on january 6. deputy chief
of staff chris lydell as well as keith
kellogg national security advisor to
former vice president mike pence who was
reportedly watching tv coverage of the
capital attack with the former president
and senior adviser stephen miller
this appeal process will likely play out
quickly because the national archives is
set to release hundreds of pages of
documents to the january 6th committee
on friday a spokesman for the former
president says he is dedicated to
defending the constitution and seeing
this process through gail
all right chris thank you very much